it was a great opportunity to see her
Embrace a character that I think was so
well played she really just like took
the character and went in a direction
that worked and that show went with that
idea that embraced all the aspects of
who vignette was and how some of that
played into hukara is I thought if we
were peaceful they'd show us Mercy
but now we know the truth if they shoot
at US Nail our heads against a wall they
will pay for it in their own blood
true of phyla too you know I mean there
was a lot of complexity around who that
character is and coming to terms with
his very side and coming to terms with
you know having been raised to human and
raised institutionalized and then trying
to like have like one sense of his self
understanding his history and where he's
come from but stepping into the freedom
of who it is and means to be a Fae while
it's falling apart and we can't just sit
at home and do nothing what have you got
in mind
bringing those two things together was
really challenging but um it kind of
worked in some ways I know that fans are
going to be sad to see the series go
given the the Deep lore and the complex
characters would you be open to
returning to this world and these
characters honestly it was it was played
out exactly as it was first as it was
intended and I think that we really kind
of put a really good button on the end
of the show
foreign